philippe le gal bonjour vous êtes le
président de l'association jean monnet
alors nous sommes ici à bazoches dans la
maison de jean bonnet qui devenu
aujourd'hui maison maison de l'europe
pour l'appel à écouter on peut l'appeler
mais oui les sources de l'europe
peut-être de l'euro mais c'était c'était
sa maison de campagne non c'était sa
maison principale principal a pas deux
campagnes mais selon péladeau à partir
de 1945 quand il est revenu de
washington et qu'il est que de gaulle le
nomme commissaire au plan il cherche un
pied-à-terre à paris parce qu'il est
originaire de cognac qui n'a pas de
pied-à-terre appareil doit parler et il
lui fallait un pied-à-terre à la fois
proche de paris mais surtout à la
campagne parce qu'il commençait toujours
sa journée par deux heures de marche
dans la main dans l'est dans l'espace
ouvert dans l'autre véhicule est dans la
nature pour réfléchir à sa façon son
travail du jour à ses projets etc donc
il fallait il fallait de la place est
ici qu il est décédé un il est décédé
également ici en 1979 donc il est resté
ici toujours de 1945 en 1979 avec
l'interruption où il était président
enfin le premier oui président de la
haute autorité du charbon et de l'acier
a luxembourg quelque chose pendant les
premières années mais autrement il et il
était tout le temps ici alors jean
claude et c'est un nom qu'on évoque de
temps en temps elle a viré voir la
campagne
pour les européennes donc on parle de
temps en temps de jean monnet le père de
l'europe avec robert schuman nouveau les
gens connaissent mal au fond sa vie
donc il n'y a qu'à dire qu il est né à
cognac à la fin du 19e siècle en 1888
dans une famille de négociants de cognac
qui était intéressante parce que ça a
été une des premières si ce n'est la
première coopérative de petits
producteurs qui avait été fondée par son
père jean gabriel
monnet
pour justement que les petits
producteurs et puisse rivaliser avec les
grosses maisons voilà voilà et cette
idée elle et elle est déjà très présente
chez le jeune jean monnet puisque il
sait que voilà il pour quand on est
petit pour peser il faut s'allier alors
sur la pression très haut fonctionnaire
un têtard donc il a fait des études d'un
formidable pas du tout pas du tout je
l'aï pas du tout il a il ils n'étaient
pas je pense qu'il est il avait un
esprit très brillant son père l'avait
décelée mais il est son esprit les
études koala s'accommodait mal de
l'éducation telle qu'on la pratique est
en effet à l'époque et à l'âge de 16 ans
il a la première partie de son
baccalauréat ça se faisait en deux roues
et à l'âge de 16 ans son père décide de
l'envoyer à londres apprendre à l'école
de la vie le métier de négociant il
l'envoie chez son
représentant à londres qui vend le
cognac est là pendant deux ans il est
plongé au coeur de la city est déjà à
l'époque en début du 20e siècle on sait
la place césar sial évidemment mondial
et il apprend donc le métier de
commercial de négociants les échanges
les gérants l'onglet il apprend
l'anglais revient à 10,1 pouces
parfaitement bilingue ce qui était rare
à léry tard on apprenait plus tôt
l'allemand quand on était dans les
grandes écoles militaires etc on
apprenait plus tôt l'allemand l'anglais
c'est une est une langue on peut
réserver aux commerces étaient pas très
bien vu et à 18 ans son père ben quand
il revient avec cette formation lui dit
maintenant tu vas aller voir nos grands
clients travers le monde et l'envoie
d'abord en amérique du nord ces grands
voyageurs et au canada sont tirées de la
ja j'y mets le pied la première fois à
montréal donc il fallait s'imaginer en
travaux on faisait la traversée en
bateau s'allumant longtemps et son père
lui dit n'en portent aucun livre avec
toi
personne ne peut penser à ta place
regarde autour de toi parle aux gens va
vers les autres bons donc c'est un
conseil d'ailleurs qu'il va garder toute
sa vie et qui ne il cite dans ses
mémoires donc c'est à 92 89 ans il
rédige ses mémoires et il se souvient
encore de ce que lui a dit son père
alors ça c'est donc la partie entreprise
familiale il va y vais y revenir
d'ailleurs par la suite et puis comment
comment ils rentrent au faux en contact
avec être le gouvernement et
l'administration
d'une part vend du cognac s'était pas
vendre n'importe quoi c'était en la
france un certain des clients mais quand
même de haut niveau on dirait des
clients etc je peux montrer ça
absolument ça c'est la bouteille du
centenaire c'était la bouteille fétiche
de jean monnet est d'ailleurs qu'il
réservait à ses collaborateurs les plus
méritants chaque année ce qui avait le
mieux travaillé avec à cette bouteille
là et de bouteille spéciale anniversaire
et bien à bord ils se fait un réseau je
dirais assez vite assez jeune
mais en effet ça ne suffit pas expliqué
pourquoi un moment ils basculent vers
les a fait rire publique tomiko eh bien
c'est la première guerre mondiale et
comme beaucoup d'hommes de cette
génération la première guerre mondiale a
été un tournant
majeur
irréversible c'est à dire qu'à la
première guerre mondiale
il n'est pas mobilisée mais c'était pas
forcément quelque chose
here for men who will et il est réformé
pour raison de santé parce qu'il avait
attrapé une fièvre typhoïde dans ses
voyages en egypte et puis à l'époque il
faut savoir que sur une classe d'âge on
en mobilise et au début de la guerre de
14 environ un tiers oui c'est ça on a
l'impression que tout le monde lorsqu'il
fallait garder aussi un homme derrière
de retravailler pour faire les récoltes
etc donc il n'est pas mobilisée et salle
embête beaucoup jean monnet parce qu'il
a beau être déjà très mondiale
mondialistes voyageurs il est jeune et
il veut faire quelque chose pour sa
patrie et à ce moment là il ya un
premier mystère est aussi un un miracle
quelque part c'est qu'il arrive par les
contacts du du cognac je dirais à avoir
un entretien avec l'équivalent du
premier ministre aujourd'hui rené
viviani à bordeaux puisque le
gouvernement est un devoir et et
aborderont 8 et à cognac donc sera très
loin et il arrive à rencontrer viviani
dans son bureau pendant un court
entretien et lui dit voilà monsieur le
président du conseil les choses ne
marchent pas bien j'ai observé comment
le ravitaillement se fait entre nos deux
pays la grande bretagne et la france
nous sommes censés être allié or nous ne
sommes pas du tout allié nous sommes
compétiteurs marché nous sommes
concurrents et tout ça il est
désorganisée et moi je suis un homme
d'organisation je connais le fret
maritime
je peux vous dire que tout ça c'est
absolument une gabegie on perd deux on
va perdre la guerre faire au talent de
l'argent
annonça à rené visuel et et viviani est
convaincu que ce jeune homme en tout cas
et à une volonté de fer il lui dit bah
écoutez si vous sentez de le faire je
vous envoie à londres et organiser ça
avec les anglais il dit moi je connais
très bien les anglais gt et véhicules et
donc il est soutenu pour sa part un
ministre quand même s'appeler clémentel
mini du commerce qui soutient monnaies
parce que beaucoup de militaires etc lui
mettront des bâtons dans les roues on
apprécie pas qu'un jeune homme de 23 ans
viennent expliquer comment on doit
travailler avec les alliés donc bon mais
il arrive par la persuasion et pendant
toute la guerre il met en place la
première guerre mondiale il met en place
ce pool commun de ravitaillement
franco-britannique qui garantit à la
fois l'acheminement et l'achat au bon
prix des matières premières et puis
ensuite des arts déjà renforts
américains
pardon non mais c'est là que ça va se
passer c'est l'aspect après il est nommé
numéro 2 de l'ancêtre de l'onu de la
société des nations et s'il regarde il a
29 ans il est dit que je n'y
arriverais réversible et parvenir dans
son premier maître et il va à peu près
avoir la même fonction pendant pendant
la deuxième guerre alors pendant la
deuxième guerre il veut évidemment
recommencer cela sauf que la situation
actuelle cydia sur la d 40
irait à londres et d'ailleurs il est à
l'ondé le juste avant l'appel du g1 17
jose 3 1 il propose l'union franco
britannique c'est à dire qu'il a jean
monnet ne s'arrête jamais à 1
ils considèrent jamais qu'un projet né
est infaisable ici au contraire ils
l'ont projet fou n'est plus faux le
tenter et face à ce qu'il voit comme
étant la capitulation de la france il
dit il faut que les armées françaises
qui n'ont pas qu'ils sont encore repliés
s'unissent aux britanniques parce
qu'avec les brics à 10 et à sa grande
idée dès le début ça c'est l'union koala
si on est plus lent qui on est unis on
est plus fort qu'il ya plus de
gouvernement français que la france est
occupée ben il faut au moins que de ceux
qui restent s'unissent au britannique et
ont fait un gouvernement commun l'union
franco britannique le temps de la guerre
jorge s'il accepte cette proposition
mais c'est ce qui va alors il reçoit de
gaulle je crois chez lui 1 juste avant
l'appel du dow est à londres comme on
l'appelle des 10 juin mais c'est un peu
ce qu'ils veulent c'est pas drôle parce
que de gaulle
il ya la france doit rester la france
soit un bond de gaulle à l'époque
d'abord né et est un représentant du
gouvernement c'est un ministre y bon on
peut un mini des affaires étrangères
militaire et c'est dire donc de gaulle
pour le moment sur le projet de monnaie
ne devienne ne dit rien et dit je vais
aller ont parlé au gouvernement il part
avec simplement entre temps
le gouvernement tombe pétain river est
signe l'armistice donc de vol n'aura pas
le temps de présenter le projet et
ensuite il part sur tout à fait autre
chose à lille rare sur cette résistance
de la france etc et la monnaie dit
normes et ça c'était c'est une
résistance vaines seuls les britanniques
peuvent faire quelque chose avec le
soutien des américains il ya déjà
lorsque les dires des races est qu on le
verra après sur la construction
européenne il ya déjà un désaccord à oui
mais ils se connaissaient mais ils
n'étaient pas d'accord sur les sur les
moyens en effet et même si par la suite
monnaie
aidera de gaulle à s'imposer vis-à-vis
des américains dont on arrive est
évidemment à la fin de la guerre et
c'est là l'idée continue de germer au
lui quoi qu'il faut s'unir c'est à dire
que
il est basé aux états unis il a en 1945
il a toutes les données économiques des
tous les services secrets lui font
remonter les données vrai les véritables
données il s'aperçoit que la france
complètement ruinée et va mettre
beaucoup plus de temps même que ses
voisins à remonter la pente et là il en
parle au général de gaulle il lui dit il
faut absolument remaut dernis et la
france qui est en retard
remettre la force sur les rails il faut
un plan il faut un plan et moi je peux
faire ce plan par secteur économique en
mettant tout le monde autour de la table
que ce soit le monde de l'entreprise des
syndicats les technocrates les
ingénieurs on va tous travailler
ensemble et de gaulle lui dit va écouter
monnaie si vous pensez pouvoir le faire
fait lever tôt et c'est comme ça qu'il
arrive en 1945 pour faire cela il
devient comme secret le il crée le poste
de doyen charia au plan et le concept de
plan b qui va participer dos carré en
parallèle il s'occupe de la france mais
en parallèle il réfléchit déjà depuis
1943 à l'avenir de l'est de l'europe et
en particulier la maintenant puisqu'on
est dans une période où les choses se
sont arrêtés je dirais à berlin où
l'allemagne est coupée en deux ou une
partie de l'europe est sous domination
communiste
soviétique et l'autre partie plutôt donc
sous domination américaine et
occidentale
là ils défaut il faut absolument que
l'europe s'unisse voilà sinon on repart
donc et une idée révolutionnaire encore
je vous arrête parce que le bain le
temps est de la partie touche à sa fin
je vous propose qu'on reprenne cette
conversation parce que là on va voir
évidemment parce que tous les problèmes
qui se posent à l'europe aujourd'hui
c'est à dire ce qu'il faut aussi dire
plus s il veut faire un lien entre la
france et l'allemagne c'est un peu le
débat entre entre monnaies de gaulle qui
est déjà sur la table cette époque là
donc je propose qu'on parle de ça dans
une autre émission merci beaucoup si
l'on prévienne beaucoup